en el día mundial del medio ambiente un
perro chileno ayuda a crear conciencia
sobre el reciclaje todo comenzó cuando
el border collie junto con su dueño
empezaron a recoger una y otra vez la
basura que dejan los visitantes de la
mayor zona verde de la capital chilena
una ilustradora tomo la historia de sam
y lo convirtió en un cómic alzarlo
reflejan súper bien el artista que hizo
él
las ilustraciones logró captar mucho ver
lo que estás am y el mensaje mismo del
del instructivo como está plasmado
también es el mensaje y yo siento que es
el correcto porque estos lugares no son
los cuales a los que uno tiene que traer
basura sólo en abril recolectaron 602
mascarillas
585 botellas y 304 latas además de ropa
cascos y envoltorios de comida los
responsables del parque quedaron
impresionados por sam y decidieron
utilizar su imagen en su campaña de
cuidado del parque de que visitantes
como sam son
increíbles de ejemplos para que puedan
conocer todos nuestros visitantes y que
puedan seguir su ejemplo y seguir se
línea sólida no solamente en el trabajo
con la basura y cuidar no dejar basura
en nuestro parque sino que puedan
acompañarnos en esta estructura de
trabajo en esta forma de trabajo en esta
forma de mirar el día a día santiago
buscando hacer cada vez más cuidadoso
con el medio ambiente cuidar nuestros
bosques cuidar nuestros parques el
personaje del cómic es un perro con capa
de superhéroe que ayuda a limpiar el
parque el cómic ha superado las
expectativas en las redes sociales y
gracias a la historia de sam superhéroe
de cuatro patas los vendedores de
bebidas cambiaron los vasos de plástico
por los de vidrio e iniciaron programas
educativos de clasificación de la basura